today's topic
we got a part two on soho karen mia
poncero the lovely lady who brought you
enough
enough the daddy hat i'm sorry that you
felt tackled
i do sincerely from the bottom of my
heart apologize that if i made
the sun feel as if i assaulted him or if
i hurt his feelings
i'm sorry that you felt crunched all
right so what's the update people sent
us a bunch of other videos about her
trying to give us more information and
all this other stuff so
um so give you guys a big context um
someone suspected that
she was drinking and driving so they
called the cops and followed her the
cops ended up coming up and this is when
they got
pulled over i think they ran away from
the cops at some point during this
arrest
attempt it was not even because of the
thing what it was oh this is a separate
incident completely
yes that happened after before
oh can i see
[Music]
than five times now you should listen
please listen worst thing to do
if you're a bystander if you be in the
cops's face
he gonna get pissed off he gonna [ __ ]
you up wait wait wait wait wait
but if you're a woman you get a couple
passes yeah you get of course
this was a big old [ __ ] he's in
handcuffs
handcuffs i mean handcuffs
[Music]
imagine if they showed this much
patience with like
negroes from the hood as they do these
valley girls you touch a cop that's
crazy bro like she didn't just touch him
she touched him around
the waist area what's around his waist
his gun
you try to reach from that's what that's
done but this
this shows to you how much society
doesn't view women as threats
or people that need to be held
accountable because even in moments
where most dudes would either be in
prison or
shot and killed they still get a pants
yeah
i can't even point a cop i ask this
question sometimes to my white friends
i'm like
okay situation if you stop at a there's
a cop card
at the red light okay and you're next to
the cop and the the light turns green
what do you do do you let the cop pass
or you go
i mean i yeah you let the cop pass wrong
answer you never park next to a cop
is wrong with you you park behind and if
you it's the only place you don't park
directly next to it you park behind [ __ ]
is wrong with you
what i prefer to do is to roll up right
beside him and then roll down the window
and let a bunch of smoke come out and
just look i'll be like
shut up dude
what's the thing you took away from this
video that gang members don't kill
people they steal phones
sorry what do you think of it what i
took away from it is i understand why
she is the way that she is
yeah she got drunk she got behind the
wheel
and who was in her passenger seat her
mom
that's her mom it's her mom [ __ ] out of
here it's her mom get the
get yo take all your sh get the [ __ ] out
of here
that's her mom that's her mom
mia's arrest happened on october 3rd in
ventura county
the 22 year old was charged with dui
resisting arrest and obstructing a peace
officer or emt
again on film she appeared completely
out of control
the drama started when mia and her mom
nicole stepped up
okay okay okay okay spot spot spots
pause now that's just going to focus i
don't want to spread any faith in
permission so i'm glad we confirmed it
because i was pretty sure okay so
preach you know where i'm going just go
me i'm just going to be dancing next to
it because i need to
i need to pass i need to let this this
entitlement go
just just say speaker me
hmm i have to speak to my ancestors
right right okay peep king
this girl got behind the wheel and got
drunk with her mom
basically putting everybody else on the
road at risk drunk driving
extremely dangerous her mom gets in the
car with her
doesn't try to stop her was like let's
go then they get together and they also
run away from cops after they try to
stop them
then they get to the stop where the
daughter's getting arrested if she
failed the breathalyzer
and the mom rather than trying to hold
her daughter accountable for the bad
decisions she makes tries to defend her
from the law enforcement even though she
put everyone at risk
now do you understand why this person is
incapable of accountability
i almost feel bad because it started
with the parents
the way that they raised her and the
values that they give that is the
responsibility of
parents to instill that in their
children that's why you don't want to
raise kids that if they weren't your
kids you would hate
that's what she is it's just looking at
her she doesn't respect law enforcement
she doesn't care about anybody else's
safety she doesn't care about people she
hurts
and she doesn't believe in taking
responsibility and
being accountable for what she does yes
okay failure as a person she's failed
deserves her punishment send her to jail
all that stuff i agree but what's the
bigger picture here
her parent raised her to be that way
trickle down
accountability crazy messed up
i couldn't believe it when i found out
the woman that was touching cops
trying to pull her out trying to get out
of trouble was drunk in the car with her
mom
yo
so how can you expect her to have
awareness as an adult to be like yeah i
was wrong for doing that her whole life
her parents have taught her that she
doesn't do any wrong even when police
have
proof and it's on camera her mom is
trying to say no she didn't do nothing
where's your warrant your warrant for a
dui are you crazy
how much of a bubble do you live in who
needs a warrant for a dui
what are you talking about she actually
said that she said that she said that
she said
why is heroin even the lawyer dropped
her because like she's like yo this
girl's unstable
and you could clearly see this girl zero
self-awareness
zero understanding of what repercussions
mean but the thing is that for the
lawyer is that it's gonna
it's gonna affect her reputation of
reputation did you even hear
the lawyer at one point she goes dale
stop the lord's like stop stop stop stop
enough the hotel did have my phone when
she went
when she went enough you see the whole
lawyer goes on
tv that's the subtext of that yeah
that's the worst kind of client that a
lawyer can get because whenever we're
going to stick to a plan to
to get you something you're not going to
stick to it you're going to be all crazy
and shooting it's just you're gonna make
you lose waste your time
waste of time it's it's hard for me to
comprehend this is a
failure honestly bro that's crazy
i wish my kid would my kid assault
someone like that you know i tell them
do your time and you know what i hate
whenever i see stuff like that
there's always these bastard [ __ ]
dumbass [ __ ] parents
they're gonna come up to me like yeah
but you don't have kids you can't
understand
shut up i am not a firefighter but i
know when there's a fire and
that come on now you failed whether i
have kids or not you let her drive
you let her escape when she when she
when cops are doing their job wow cops
were actually doing their job you know
what
we sh i i'm not gonna say we ah i have
this relationship with cops it is what
it is
and i don't like him and it is that's
that if you're
a cop you're outside of your uniform we
can have beers and [ __ ] like that and
i'll drive after though
we could have beers and stuff like that
everything but once you're in your
uniform you're not a civilian you're on
that side you know
adele a hello from the other side okay
that's you
and it's not it's i'm i'm not i don't
hate you because i hate you
i hate you because it's for my safety
okay it is what it is
now that being said cops are actually
doing their job
you understand you made me side with the
cops do you understand how
[ __ ] up you have to be for me to side
with the cops
but that's just a mess that's a whole
mess that's a whole ass mess
and you probably still excuse her like
yeah no you know she's a good i'm a
sweet person
i'm a sweet person i'm a good pers
i think a lot of parents are not able to
tell the line between
when protection goes from indulging
and uh there's a point you cross where
you try to protect your child so much
that you are basically insulating them
from the lessons the world needs to
teach them
in order for them to be functioning
adults what you're seeing is a 22
year old dysfunctional individual this
person has real problems
a lot of people are raising kids they
hate yeah and the reason why those kids
are hateable a lot of the times it's
your fault
isn't that true absolutely as a parent
you let her down
you failed her and you failed to give
her a chance to learn something
nothing is her fault ever
that's what i'm saying i'm not going to
say you're a bad person or whatever not
but you definitely failed her and that's
sad
because now you not
taking your role of parents seriously
has consequences to other people
there's other people's lives that are
endangered
because it's never her fault people are
accused
there's consequences to your actions but
there's also consequences to your
inaction
you failing to your kid and you not
raising your kid properly
there's consequences to that you know it
makes me think of that child who tries
to stick a [ __ ] thing
fork into the the power socket right
and instead of telling the kid not to
what this parent did is she put like a
plastic cover on top of it
so the kid kept trying but failed no
what she did
was not tell the kid what's wrong and
not have to talk with a kid
the kid got electrocuted and she sued
the company because the company hurt the
kid
when she did not do her job as a parent
to be like that's no
i'm going to protect you make sure that
that but let's have that talk that
that's a no
yeah that that can potentially hurt you
no she let the kid get hurt
and then after that she sued the company
because the outlet company yeah
hurt the kid i think hopefully there's a
lesson to folks
don't don't raise your kids to be this
because she's going to jail and she's
likely going to be in and out of jail
very likely oh yeah if money doesn't
save her
she going back to jail guaranteed
there's no way she's not she's gonna do
more crazy stuff guaranteed so
that's pretty much my thoughts on this
whole matter do you have anything else
you want to know
so that's all i got tell us what you
guys think do you guys agree or disagree
with our assessment
preach do you think she's trash now
lord help me now
[Music]
foreign